Now, I'd like to ask you about what happens as the number of flips
or events, in general, becomes a very large number.
Check all that apply. The probability of every individual sequence becomes small
The probability of every number of heads becomes small.
So for example, does the probability of having one head or hundred heads or million heads,
any specific number does that becomes small.
Does the probability of every given proportion, for example, one head out of 100 flips,
10 heads out of 100 flips or 1500 heads out of a billion flips becomes small.
Does every given range of proportions have a smaller and smaller probability.
Are there some ranges of proportions for which the probability becomes small as we have many flips.
Check all that apply. Also, assume that the probability of heads is neither 0 or 1.
That is, we can get both heads and tails from this coin.